[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and i've always liked
that the ant-man movies show that no
matter what size you are you can still
get the girl it's something i relate to
a lot what
and the little guy has made a big impact
in the mcu from what we saw at san diego
comic-con ant-man and the wasp quantum
mania has the potential to be one of the
biggest or smallest movies in phase five
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down what happened in the
teaser kevin feige announced that san
diego comic-con that this will be the
first film in the phase and we know from
the trailer league that it'll introduce
kang the conqueror he was of course
brought up by he who remains at the end
of loki and there's been a lot of
chatter online after the event about how
good jonathan mages is now what's
interesting about kang is that there's
so many different versions of him in the
marvel universe whether it's rama turt
immortus victor timely iron lad or
whoever you never know which version of
kang that you're gonna get there are an
infinite number of him across the
multiverse the majority of which have
the ability to move throughout it and
therefore every time a character runs
into him it's a roll of the dice now
phase six will end with two avengers
movies in the same year both of which
will center around kang and his dynasty
so lots of things are going to be
happening in quantum mania that have big
repercussions and the first look gives
some jonathan major things away
now you've either seen people filming
the ceiling of the event of it on
twitter or you've heard people talking
about what happens in it either way i
just want to go through a bit by bit and
break down everything about it and if
you enjoy the video please hit the
thumbs up button and also don't forget
to subscribe for videos like this every
day without the way thanks for clicking
this also spoilers here now let's get
into the video okay so quantum mania
will heavily feature kang and this is
gonna be made clear from the off
according to people at the event he
narrates the new look from the beginning
and throughout it we hear him saying
you're an interesting man scott lang
you've lost a lot of time but time it's
not what you think it's not a straight
line when you can see time the way i do
you can see everything
which it annoys me about that because i
i should have been cast as kang no
anyway now this of cour it would have
been all right wouldn't it now this of
course is referring to scott getting
lost in the quantum realm after the
events of ant-man in the wasp though to
him it only felt like a handful of hours
the real world has had five years go by
and because of this his daughter aged up
from a kid to a teen baby
get that off get that off anyway we know
from the poster that cassie lang will be
returning for the movie and though she's
now played by catherine newton she'll be
a very big part of the adventure the
first poster for the film shows her in a
purple suit and it's lucky that she'll
becoming the character stinger from the
comics she was also called stature at
one point but i think they'll probably
just jump straight to stinger as it fits
better with the bug personas that the
rest of the squad have from what my
uncle could make out watching the dodgy
clip on twitter there's a tiny blue
beacon that opens up in the lab and
cassie gets sucked into this along with
the rest of the characters it seems that
they're experimenting on the quantum
realm and whether cassie opens this up
accidentally or someone from insider
pulls them in remains to be seen my
guess is that they're all taken there
though including janet who will likely
help them to navigate the dimension
this can be slightly seen in the trailer
and janna ends up donning her hooded
costume that she had on in ant-man and
the wasp when hank was reunited with her
we don't know exactly what she got up to
when she was down there but it seems
like she found refuge in kang city which
exists in the dimension
janet seems to be the age that she would
have been on earth and we saw with scott
that the area he was in had time moving
differently so janet likely found refuge
for the 30 odd years she was down there
and just chilled out watching heavy
spoilers amazing videos like in subway
now according to the people at the event
there's a point in it where we see the
group all journeying there and it's
filled with humanoids that have markings
on their face there's also kang's suit
from the comics which has the classic
purple helmet with a blue face covering
in the source material his skin was blue
but it looks like it's a soutier that he
uses to travel through the quantum realm
there's apparently a lot of different
looks for kang in the teaser with some
even having his mask off these could be
the same version of kang or as we've
discussed different iterations of him
from different timelines it's even
possible that we saw this location in
ant-man in the wasp and if janet found
refuge here then she could be used as a
way to give some exposition on kang
although that happened before the events
of loki when the timeline was split time
moves differently in the quantum realm
so you have things happening there after
the end of time which is when the ending
of loki took place lots of timey winey
wibbly wobbly stuff but either way kang
has encountered the avengers before or
at least versions of them in the teasers
scott says to him i don't know who you
are but you made a big mistake i am an
avenger i should have done the accent
for that my my cast in the movie anyway
kang replies by saying you're an avenger
i am a conqueror he also asks if he's
killed him before and he drops this
completely nonchalantly showing that he
may have killed an infinite number of
them across an infinite number of
timelines it's pretty wild and it
instantly sets up kang as a threat
that's not to be with nowhere as thanos
wiped out trillions of people with a
snap of his finger kangas conquered
countless timelines and in some
instances killed far more than thanos
ever could he wiped out everyone that
ever was and everyone who would ever be
in those timelines and it's all in his
quest for domination now it looks like
he's also going to be joined by the
villain modoc according to rumors on the
film he will be played by corey stoll
who played darren cross in the first
ant-man film you'll probably remember
that he ended up getting stuck in the
quantum realm himself and he likely got
picked up by kang and drafted into his
forces originally in the comics murdoch
was a character called george tarleton
but it looks like they've changed things
up a bit and honestly i think it works
better with the story we don't really
need a big origin breakdown during the
movie if he's simply cross so cross that
off your list you stupid [ __ ] his
design has been slightly changed up and
he's now more like a cyborg rather than
being a giant human head anyway other
miscellaneous things that happen are
that we see bill murray at one point
taking his glasses off we don't know
which character that he is and as of now
we don't know anything beyond him
seemingly knowing janet now there are
rumors that he's playing cry law a
character who popped up in the
incredible hulk issue 156. krylov was
introduced and killed in the same issue
so there's very little to go off with
him however he did live in the
microverse so yeah he'll likely be
someone who lives in the quantum realm
under kang's command and marvel don't
actually own the rights to use the word
microverse hence the change to quantum
realm oh i would have loved the name
microversamania either way he does seem
to know janet so maybe he was a loving
trust with her while she was down there
which would make things a bit awkward
with hank if you want to be happy living
a king's life
never make a pretty woman your wife
don't quote me on that though cause i
might be wrong and i judge it sorry i
mean my uncle judged it off watching the
corner of a video filmed on a phone now
he has glasses on that he takes off and
we could see in the first look that he
looks human so whether it's him or they
did a different design we just don't
know moonlight did something similar to
where they took a very obscure character
in arthur harrow and it just means that
they can really do what they want with
him while still giving a nod to the
comics now murray has kept tight-lipped
about it too and when asked about the
project he said that he doesn't normally
do movies like this but he's simply just
like peyton reed and got on with him
it's a nice reason to join it and
there's also a couple of cute shots that
we get in the trailer these center
around scott reading his own book out at
an event the character of course read a
lot after the events of civil war when
he was under house arrest and he's now
become somewhat of a celebrity the book
is titled look out for the little guy
and it'll also complement his podcast
which was brought up during ms marvel
apparently this has turned him into a
bit of a celebrity and instead of
staying a hero he's been out of action
and has focused on this for a while we
actually see him and hope at a premiere
at one point and he's carved out a big
name for himself i got a lot of vibes
watching i mean my uncle got a lot of
vibes watching it and hopefully he has
better luck in the bedroom than termite
does he then gets a call from jail and
after picking it up he's connected to
cassie she's sort of doing what he used
to do and breaking the law but for the
right reasons however he doesn't want
her to waste her life behind bars like
he did he brings up saving the world
again which hank calls him out for as
apparently he always does it now this
has created a gap between the pair and
at the moment they have a strained
relationship due to his constant need to
brag i think because of that this movie
is going to be about humbling scott on a
number of levels time to make that ego
shrink down too and we're not only going
to have his daughter taking him down a
pega 2 but also kang i really think kang
is going to wipe the floor with him in
this movie and that it'll end on him
losing which will set the villain up as
a major threat scott will probably get a
win against modok but kang has all the
angles covered and can probably beat him
on a number of levels beating the guy
who saved the entire world wowzer wowzer
what a bloody great victory but i think
it's definitely gonna set the stage for
how dangerous that kang is i originally
thought the movie might be some goofy
trip through the quantum realm but by
the sounds of it it's gonna be extremely
important the ant-man movies have always
been sort of wild caught in the mcu and
though they're mainly comedies they do
have their big moments and even a lot of
stuff that had big ramifications in
avengers end game it's all building to
kang dynasty and secret wars which we
now know will be directed by destin
daniel crenton he's coming hot off the
heels of chongqi and it's going to be
interesting to see what the character
does with it anyway from what my uncle
could make out the trailer looks really
good and i am excited to see where they
take things next obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the movie and what
you hope to see in it so make sure you
that was pretty [ __ ] crap that one so
make sure you comment below and let me
know now we are in competition right now
and giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
the winners of the last one will be on
screen right now so if that's you then
message me on twitter heavyspoilers if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
daredevil born again which will be
linked on screen right now that's my
most anticipated thing from the upcoming
slate and if you're interested in it
then definitely head over there right
after this by the way thanks for sending
you the video i've been paul i'll see
you next time take care peace
man from a logical point of view
better marry a woman uglier than you